- Our next presenter is Chitra Ramalingam,
who is lecturer in History
of Science and Medicine,
as well as History.
Professor Ramalingam is
a historian of science
and a historian of photography.
Her research, teaching and
curatorial work range broadly
across topics in science and
visual and material culture,
with a particular focus on
the visual culture of physics
in the 19th and 20th centuries.
On 19th century ways of seeing,
especially optical
illusions, optical toys,
and the prehistory of cinema.
The early history of photography.
Changing discourses about
photography as art or science
and Decolonial Museum Practice.
Her first book,
"To see a spark: Experiment
and visual experience
in Victorian science," uses the history
of a single scientific
object, the electric spark,
to track how physicists
manage their visual experience
in the laboratory.
She has co-edited a volume
of essays by art historians
and historians of science
on the photographic pioneer
and Victorian gentlemen of science,
William Henry Fox Talbot.
Titled, "William Henry Fox
Talbot: Beyond Photography."
And co-curated an
exhibition on Talbot in 2010
at the Wren Library
University of Cambridge.
She's curated exhibitions
on early photography
on antiquarianism and
architectural photography
and on social portraiture in
post 1945 British photography.
Ongoing projects include a
book project on the laboratory
as image archive in the
Modern Physical Sciences.
A material history of Talbot's
photographic publication,
"The Pencil of Nature," in collaboration
with conservation scientists
at Yale's institution
for the preservation of cultural heritage.
"Fixing and Fading."
Photographic histories and exhibition
and book on the science
and aesthetics of fading
in 19th Century and
contemporary photography.
And "Out of Place," a series
of experimental installations
involving re-situating objects
from Yale's natural history collections
about which we'll hear more.
Welcome Professor Ramalingam.
(audience clapping)
Thank you.
- Hi, everybody.
Hold on. Let me just get situated here.
Thank you so much to the
organizers of this event
for giving us all the opportunity
to think broadly and
humanistically together
across Yale collections and resources,
and I'm especially glad to
be following Ned Cooke who's,
I've had some of the most kind of humbling
and illuminating experiences
that I've had at Yale
have been in the teachings
that he described
to organizing earlier.
So, I wanna talk to you
all today about some work
that emerged out of my own
interdisciplinary practice.
As a curator and an academic,
working between History of Science,
History of Art and Museum Studies.
A few years ago,
I started a project which
I called "Out of Place,"
which is a kind of ongoing
research engagement
with Yale's varied collections.
And in this project, I'm working with
a number of various
wonderful collaborators,
both on and off campus
to bring seemingly
unconnected, unrelated objects
from the universities, museums
of science, art and culture
into conversation with one another.
And this project will result in a series
of online publications and displays
over the next two or three years.
There's one plan for the
Yale University Art Gallery.
Hopefully, the Peabody Museum
when they re-open in 2024
and also at the Tarq Gallery in Mumbai
and hopefully other venues as well.
So, today I wanna explain
to you all the process
and the practice behind the
first outcome of this project,
which I've called, "A British Mineralogy,"
in which I collaborated
with an Indian artist
based in Delhi named Garima Gupta.
This project explores the
histories and layered geographies
and visual landscapes of minerals
at Yale's Peabody Museum
of Natural History.
So, in a natural history display
like this classic teaching
display of minerals
that you can see on the left
from Yale's Peabody Museum,
natural objects like minerals
from across the globe
are typically identified with
a specific locality of origin.
So, the one place which it is known
to have occurred in nature.
All other places through which that object
may have passed on route to the museum,
on its passage through
human culture and history
are not usually relevant.
In the collections of the
Yale Center for British Art,
which you can see on the right,
and where I worked as photography curator
until a few months ago,
there are objects made in
places around the British Isles,
but also all around the world
made by people of many backgrounds
become notionally British
by virtue of being there.
Geopolitical relations for
certain periods of time,
bound those people in places to Britain,
to its state, its fortunes
and its aesthetic styles,
sometimes creating rich hybrid
styles like the so-called
Company School of Indian Painting Masters
such as Shaikh Zain ud-Din.
Natural history museums
of course are understood
to tell us powerful stories about nature
while we go to art museums to
hear and see powerful stories
about culture and identity.
Now, this project arose from a number
of generative dissonances,
I guess I would say,
that I experienced during
my four years as a curator
at the Yale Center for British Art.
So on the one hand,
disciplinary dissonance
as a cultural historian of science
employed in an art museum.
But then on a more personal level,
also as a diasporic
Indian-American at an institution
whose unstable vision of British art
depended so much on
exoticized images of people
in places of the global South.
So, as I kind of was
conducting my work there
on the photography collection,
which is not related to
what I'm showing you today,
I kept thinking about what other histories
were entangled with the
history of British art
within the walls of that institution,
but were unable or unavailable rather
via the museum's fine art collections,
its disciplinary methods and
its conventions of display.
Gradually, I came to hone in
on the Peabody's mineralogy collection
and it'll become clear why
I turned there in a moment.
I selected a group of 10 mineral specimens
in conversation with the
collection manager at Peabody.
The collection manager for
minerals and meteoritics.
These 10 objects are,
it's actually technically
I think 13 objects,
but as you can see,
some of them are grouped by mineral type.
They were originally
gathered from locations
in the British Isles, but
also in Southern Africa,
Eastern Australia, Sri
Lanka and Western India.
They were collected at the Peabody
from around the mid 19th Century
through the early 21st centuries.
Each of them passing first
through British networks
of power, knowledge, value and exchange.
At its height, as you probably know,
at the start of the 20th century,
the British Empire famously
encompassed the entire earth,
not only with respect to territories
under direct colonial control,
but also wider business
and trade interests.
This is a map of the British-controlled
global telegraphy network,
around I think 1901.
Yeah.
But British Imperial
ambitions did not simply aim
to cover the earth's surface.
They also sought to reach deep
below the Earth's surface.
Mining and engineering in
Britain and its former empire
are associated with global histories
of migration, inequality,
and exploitation.
With the transformation of terrain
and with ecological disasters,
past present and future.
So these 10 objects, which
I called migrant minerals,
they contained valuable materials
from the prosaic to the precious.
Graphite tin, copper, diamond and more.
And they were brought forth from the earth
through the skilled labor of people
whose lives became entangled with them
and with the technological landscapes
of extraction around them.
And these are images of the
Kimberly Mines in South Africa.
One of the most notorious
diamond mines in the region.
Some of these images are
from Yale collections
like this stereo pair
and the others are not.
Once unearthed,
these objects embarked on
voyages across the globe,
participating in the global
flows of people and commodities
that underlay British power
in a period of high empire.
And finally,
they were assimilated into
a natural history collection
where they shed some of these pasts
in order to become emblems of nature,
apparently outside culture
and outside history.
They had become mineralogical specimens.
So in this project, I was
asking what kind of mineralogy
might embrace and acknowledge
these stories of excavation,
translocation, transformation and arrival?
Rather than effacing them
in the name of nature.
And I ended up calling this
project, "A British Mineralogy."
And in this I was inspired
or more precisely, I was provoked
by the London artist and
naturalist, James Sowerby.
In the early 19th Century,
Sowerby published a multi-volume treatise,
which he called, "British Mineralogy."
So, no article. Just British mineralogy,
This was the first major illustrated
mineralogical publication in Europe.
Issued in installments
between 1804 and 1817,
Sowerby's work was visually groundbreaking
with 550 hand-colored engravings
based on individual mineral specimens.
There were two sets of books.
So, the first volumes,
"British Mineralogy,"
were followed a few years
later by their counterpart,
which was a large single volume
called "Exotic Mineralogy."
But Sowerby regularly undermined
his own proposed distinction
between the British
in his first set of volumes
and the exotic in the final set.
In his text, the words
British, English, Native,
foreign and exotic
carried a lot of weight.
And there were suggestive slippages
and ambiguities throughout.
Both the British and the
exotic mineralogy project
for Sowerby were limited
to reproducing specimens
that were held in London-based
mineral collections,
which themselves depended of course,
upon networks of British
travelers to distant lands.
And in his project, even a meteorite,
so a piece of stone that was theorized
to a fallen from the heavens,
an object that's
literally from outer space
was found to be British.
It was included as part
of British mineralogy.
In the fifth volume,
Sowerby observed what has
been thought remarkable
is that this work on British
mineralogy should include
so many subjects previously
considered as foreign.
So, I was looking through
Sowerby's drawings and his text
while I researched these
10 mineral specimens.
And I began to wonder
what it would look like
to propose a different
kind of British mineralogy.
Sowerby's work was an exercise
in drawing the boundaries
of locale and belonging and Britishness
in a quite different way than
either the Peabody Museum
or the Yale Center for British Art did.
Or for that matter, quite
different from how a present day
UK immigration officer
would draw those boundaries.
His drawings did not depict the landscapes
from which those specimens were extracted
or the people involved in doing so,
although his text did
occasionally describe
both the people or the landscapes.
And so, it was at this
point that I realized
that my project could not simply be
what it had been originally
conceived as which was,
it was going to be an
exhibition of minerals
accompanied by a text that was grounded
in my historical research into the object.
But the more time I spent with Sowerby,
the more urgently I felt
that this project required
a visual practice as a part of it.
A non-textual way of
restoring a multilayered
sense of place and
belonging to each object.
And at this point in my research,
I had begun to assemble
a kind of visual archive
for each mineral as I researched it.
So, I was finding historical
photographs, diagrams,
maps, printed texts, and other documents,
many of which were in Yale collection,
some of which were things
I had accessed digitally elsewhere.
And all the historical images
that I'm showing you today
are from this archive that I assembled.
And I felt like something
needed to be done with them
as part of this project.
Something thoughtful that
didn't just reproduce
the visual conventions
of the colonial gaze.
And in any case, I was
sometimes in this research
coming across disturbing
and graphic imagery
of abuse and violence,
including things that I found
in Yale collections again.
Images that I couldn't
bring myself to even save
in my database, let alone
contemplate publishing.
And this was when I came across the work
of the Indian artist and researcher,
Garima Gupta based in Delhi.
And I'm showing you the work here by her
that caused me to reach out
to her in the first place.
Garima's work is about
the environmental history
of South and Southeast Asia.
She makes drawings,
observational drawings of natural objects.
Rocks, plants, animals.
And then she layers them with drawings
of archival materials that
she's found in her own research.
And she does this in order to make sense
of the visual and ecological legacies
of trade and migration histories
and European colonial
expansion in the region.
And so in the work shown here,
she uses a leaf of paper
from the account books
of an oil palm plantation
company in Malaysia
as the basis for a drawing
of two oil palm flower
heads, male and female.
And she creates these
layered installations
of drawings in light boxes.
And so you can kind of see
the kind of documentary layer
and the observational drawing layer
kind of merging together
in these light objects.
And she does this in
order to explore visually
a conflict over land use
and ecological change
in the Malaysian archipelago.
So, I encountered this work
by her and I approached her
about a year and a half ago.
This was just before the
pandemic went global.
And she and I began a
conversation about this project
that eventually led to a full
collaboration between us.
And so, the 10 specimens
that you saw earlier,
eventually became over the
course of 2020, 10 drawings.
And I'm just gonna briefly scroll through
all 10 of them right now,
and then I'll dive deeply into one of them
before I finish my talk.
So, I'm gonna finish with the kind of the,
the rest of my talk will
be telling you the story
of this object from the
Peabody Museum here.
One of the 10 specimens that
I honed in on for this project
and the first one that I researched.
Now, the only documentation
in the Peabody archives
for this beautiful chunk
of rock and crystal
is the handwritten label
that you can see on it
and that's zoomed in on the right.
This label identifies this mineral
as apophyllite with stilbite.
And the other information
on this label helps us track
the object's origins to
a place called Bor Ghat.
A treacherous pass in the Northern part
of the Western Ghats.
The Western Ghats are a mountain range
that run up much of the
Western coast of India.
These basalt mountains were formed
through violent volcanic eruptions
around 66 million years ago.
In the mid 19th Century, they
presented a natural barrier
between the British-controlled
port city of Bombay
and the rich resources
of the Indian interior.
So, it was nearly impossible for any kind
of wheeled vehicle to
traverse these mountains.
And so, if the British
wanted Indian commodities
like silk, opium, cotton spices,
if they wanted these things
to flow efficiently overseas for trade,
they needed a rail line to
cut across the mountains.
And so in 1856, the British established
the Great India Peninsula Railway Company
and they set out to make it happen.
Laying these new rail
lines was the largest
and most labor intensive
civil engineering project
of the British government in India.
And it coincided with violent rebellions
that saw the British almost lose control
of Northern India in 1857.
The project was carried
out over seven years.
1856 to 1863.
And this place is set
right around the same time
as the construction of the Suez Canal.
The Bor Ghat works actually
employed more workers
than the Suez project.
And ultimately, it
killed many more people.
Building this rail line was dangerous work
in precipitous terrain.
There were severe extremes
of weather in the mountains
and poor sanitation in the worker camps.
Ultimately, over the seven
years of this project,
around 25,000 workers died.
Most of them from cholera
which swept every year
through the workers' camps.
But vast numbers of laborers,
around 42,000 people a year,
at the height of this project,
migrated seasonally
across an extensive part
of Western and Southern India
to work on the new railway line.
They were mostly landless
peasants and tribal people
who had been relegated to the
margins of Indian society.
Both men and women.
British railway overseers
recruited and organized
workers ethnographically.
Identifying specific cast communities
with specific labor requirements.
And so, this railway works
was also part of a process
that transformed fluid
regional community identities
into hardened stereotypes,
locked into a hierarchy
of skills and status
and a yearly cycle of
migration and contract work.
So, these railway works set
a lot of things in motion
across the mountains then.
Capital, commodities and people.
And then on a smaller scale,
they also sent minerals in motion as well,
because blasting tunnels
through the mountains
in this place, exposed dazzling caves
lined with crystals up to six feet wide.
Even today, these caves
are the world's most,
they produce the most spectacular examples
in the world of apophyllite.
This kind of crystal that only forms
in this kind of volcanic rock.
Some of the Indian earth workers
who were involved in the railway project
took large crystals from these caves,
which the caves became
known as the jewel tunnels.
And they embedded them into
the mud walls of their huts
in the worker's camps as
decoration and as trophy.
The Chief Railway Engineer
who was an Englishman
named James Barkley, had
the largest specimens saved
to distribute to natural history museums.
Some of them stayed within India,
but most were sent to Britain.
There, they enabled British
scientists and geologists
to develop theories for how
crystals like these form
following volcanic disturbances.
And one of these samples
ended up in the hands of
geologist, Nevil Story Maskelyne,
who was the keeper of minerals
at the British Museum in London.
His name is actually on the
handwritten label there.
You can't really see it, but
it says donor, N.S. Maskelyne.
He eventually gifted it to
Yale where it now resides.
So, this crystal specimen
traveled from deep inside
a mountain in Western India to
the British Museum in London,
and then finally on to New Haven.
And it did so on a journey
shaped by Indian histories
of labor, migration and transportation,
which transformed an entire landscape
and shored up British Imperial control
over the Indian sub-continent.
So, this was the story that I had begun
to delineate for myself
around this object.
The first one that I researched
as part of this project.
And I had assembled this visual archive
that I mentioned before
of photographs and maps
and engravings and charts.
Just as the pandemic upended
our plans for Garima.
Garima Gupta, the artist.
The original plan was for
her to come to New Haven,
work closely with me,
observe the objects and
make art as a result.
But amid lockdowns and
travel restrictions,
we re-conceived the project
as a remote engagement between us
mediated by high resolution
digital photography,
cloud databases, Google
documents and Zoom.
For Garima, whose work typically involves
extensive field work
and travel across Asia,
observing and drawing this
specimen of apophyllite
involved a real remaking of her practice.
She felt her way into each
specimen by zooming deep
into the digital images that
the Peabody Museum provided.
Finding in each one, a kind
of micro landscape of its own.
And when her drawing was complete,
the main observational
drawing of the specimen,
she then considered its relation
to the real former landscape
from which the specimen
had been excavated,
and to the charts and maps and diagrams
that I'd provided for her
and which we talked about
in extensive conversations.
And, you know,
she experimented with placing the drawings
against retraced maps of the
Bore Ghat railway cuttings.
And so ultimately, here is the
final work that she created.
The whole work is on the left
and then I've kind of zoomed in
on the specimen on the right.
And it's displayed on a light box
like I was explaining earlier,
so that the kind of like
multiple layers of the image
and therefore the layers of history
in this object could emerge.
And so for each the objects,
we had a kind of back and forth like this.
In my text that I wrote for each one
and the illustrations that Garima produced
were developed collaboratively
through that process.
And together, my words
and her illustrations
engage in a kind of exploratory
practice of placemaking.
Bringing into view the transformation
of the physical landscape from
which the mineral has come.
The political and social landscape
through which it has traveled.
And the surface of the object
as a landscape of its own.
This is just another example,
a close-up of her drawing of
the Kimberly Mine diamonds.
The coming into being of
a natural history specimen
is a transformative
journey in which it sheds
a richer sense of place in
its movement through culture.
And through this collaboration,
we have tried to help these
objects carry their journeys
into the present rather
than leaving them behind.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)
(clears throat)
- [Audience Member] Can
you talk a little bit more
about sort of,
other projects like this
that you've sort of come across
that you'd like to take on other ways
in which you'd like to
see this work at all?
I mean, it's very exciting
that the exhibitions
will actually come online, and so.
- Yeah.
- [Audience Member] Complete as it were.
Do you mean other projects
here at Yale as part of this?
- Yeah.
- Or do you mean? Yeah.
- Related to this.
- Yeah, yeah. Absolutely.
- [Audience Member] Question
becomes another question.
- Yeah, yeah, definitely.
So while I was at this Yale
Center for British Art,
I had the opportunity to work
with a graduate research
assistant on this project,
kind of investigating
objects and trying to find.
I had already kind of conceived
the mineralogy project on my own,
and I wanted the kind of next stage
to emerge more collaboratively
with other partners at Yale.
The student that I worked, Manoj Ghadei,
we eventually came up
with an idea together
that was fully kind of co-conceived,
such that we're now kind of co-curators,
fully equal collaborators
on the next stage of this,
which we're calling,
well, it's a provisional title right now,
but we're calling it,
"The Octant's Journey."
And so we've now, we've honed in
on an 18th Century
navigational instrument.
That's in the Peabody's
scientific instruments collection.
This is an object that's used
to establish latitude at sea,
and we are working as
part of an exhibition
on scientific instruments,
it's gonna happen at the art gallery,
the Yale University Art
Gallery in a couple of years.
We're gonna be doing
a kind of intervention
into that exhibition where
this navigational instrument
basically travels around the exhibition,
encountering objects in it
and narrating its own history
in a printed booklet and on social media.
And what we're doing is
we're playfully adapting
an 18th Century literary genre
called "The It Narrative,"
where objects that are kind of
circulating around the world
are imbued with narrative power
and tell their own stories.
And so we're kind of,
we're imagining the octant,
this navigational instrument
as a kind of stand in
for the museum visitor.
So, we're dramatizing the
process by which meaning is made
in a museum through these encounters
between the octant and these objects.
And the idea is that as it
explores objects at the gallery,
it is questioning its own role
as a kind of navigational instrument
from this period of Imperial expansion,
thinking about its own role
in astronomical expeditions,
genocide and enslavement,
extractive colonialism.
And yeah, just trying
to kind of understand
its own implication in those histories.
So that's a kind of, you know,
it's a very different sort
of a project than this.
But like this, the idea is
to kind of bring objects
that don't seem to have
anything to do with each other
and use them to really
question the categories
that have separated them in museums.
You know, cause the Yale museums,
do a lot of collaborative work together,
but still fundamentally,
they have these different
kind of conventions of display
and ways of giving meaning
to objects that illuminate them deeply,
but also hide certain aspects of them.
And I think one of the great possibilities
of interdisciplinary humanistic work
at a university like Yale
that's had a couple of years
of collecting history is that they're,
it's not just that the
collections are rich and deep
as resources for our own work,
but they are an invitation
to kind of turn the lens on
the institution themselves
and ask really important questions about,
"Why is this object here?
"Why has it been identified
as this kind of object
"rather than another kind of object?
"And what other sorts of
histories might it tell?"
Yeah.
- [Audience Member] Has there been any,
like with the museums,
permanently change how
they exhibit them at all?
Like the best looking context is that,
(mumbles) recommendation of study?
- Yeah. I mean, that's the hope.
That's the hope, right?
Is to kind of, by collaborating
with the different museums,
start to inspire changes
and kind of experiments
in how they do things.
I think maybe another way of describing
what I'm after in this
project is that I think,
and now I'm not talking about Yale,
I'm talking about kind of European
and American museums more broadly.
The place where this kind
of creative and playful
and kind of unexpected work happens
is through artist interventions, right?
Like people invite the artist to come in,
engage with the collection
and then either make work
or select work in a way
that kind of cuts across the categories
that have structured that collection.
And I really believe in that work
and I find it really powerful,
but my worry about it
is that it segregates
that kind of critical work
and says that this is
the work of the artist,
the institution kind of
follows its own kind of dynamic
that is not a part of that.
And so, you end up displaying
these kinds of interventions
rather than incorporating them
into the practice of the museum.
So, I'm really interested in finding,
you know, as a curator, I was
trying to do that from within.
I'm now working from without again,
but also very much with museums.
And so, my hope is that
we start to really,
yeah, change the way these
objects' meaning is displayed
in all these different spaces.
- Thank you.
(audience applauding)
- Thanks.
(soft music)